this is insane i am so proud of you
thank you what was it like getting into
the mindset
of the greatest of all time did you
watch
interviews old fights like walk me
through this
yeah i mean i did pretty much all of
that and more
um you know i spent a lot of time with
people um
in the south i um i got a dialect coach
i got a boxing coach i got a personal
trainer um
i watched everything he'd ever done
every piece of video
video every piece of audio um
i just really like totally immersed
myself in trying to
understand why he why he became who he
was
you know where he was coming from and
and all the things that
um that kind of went into him that
allowed him to overcome everything that
he overcame
yeah um you were hitting the gym
yeah you were getting it together
what type of transformation are we
talking
um i mean i started training for this
you know
it's funny because in the middle of
training for
this i ended up getting riverdale yeah
that's why i was in shape for that
character but i was
really training for this the whole time
and i've over the course of about a year
probably or maybe it's 18 months i
probably put on about 20 pounds of
muscle
well damn i've been trying to do that
i don't know that'd be a lot on you i'm
sick
i don't know you want 20 pounds of
muscle you look like arnold
schwarzenegger
yo you stupid yo
i was eating you know six times a day
and um you know
you know coming to the house and at the
same time you know
he was big but he was known for how
quick
and how um loose he was in the ring or
just agile so
it was really a tough combination
because you're getting bigger you're
getting heavier you're feeling slower
but you have to get faster and faster to
try and look you know somewhat like what
he was able to do
wow so yeah yeah
when we asked regina king about you she
got excited
she lit up you know she said commitment
was very important to her and that you
had that from
the beginning uh she said thank god that
you're the right choice
because there was really no one else to
play him like
regina king she just won her award
i love her how does that feel that must
be so cool
praise jesus i i was so blessed to just
know regina and to get to
work with her um you know when she talks
about commitment
you know that's everything every detail
every
every minutia of the film is intention
i'd say if there's one word with her
it's intentional she's very
focused on making everything count
and every frame every color every sound
that you hear the
stuff that you don't even think about
the footsteps in the ring and you know
there's people that do all that stuff
you know when you're watching it
you don't notice it as a fan if it's
done well but you notice it notice it if
it's done poorly
and she was really really focused on
all those elements and of course casting
goes into that as well
and i really feel like she you know she
knew what she wanted
and i was blessed to be in a position
where i was already training
for this character because i had gone
for a film
which i didn't get but the film would
have been made
and then i decided i was going to do a
play about cassius clay
um so i was just in advance for about
two and a half years and then this
opportunity came
um so just one of those great lessons
yeah you don't have to get ready when
you stay ready
[Laughter]
that was my philosophy it paid out it
paid off
what was it like having regina direct
you
regina like you know i feel like i've
said this a few times now but she
similar to what clint eastwood uh or um
you know some other actors she is known
for acting now but when it's all said
and done i really truly feel like she'll
be
maybe more known for directing and she's
already got an oscar as an actress so
that's saying a lot i mean
she knows how to get the performances
she wants um from everybody she knows
how to talk to you in a language as an
actor that you can
take it in and actually you know
accomplish it
because a lot of times directors don't
know how to talk to actors they come
from a
you know technical background or they
come from a writing background
and they don't know how to give you
actionable direction
things that i can hear and do because
that's what it comes down to is like
what am i doing in front of this camera
you know and she's really good at that
um and then secondly the thing that i
think most people would be surprised by
is that she's really good with the crew
she's really good with um
you know all the elements that aren't
about acting
picking the right dops picking the right
wardrobe people the right set deck
people all those little things and those
kind of conversations and then
thirdly she just carries herself um
with a with a presence and with uh
uh confidence and real graciousness
that you really there's never a question
about
falling in line um or or having
confidence in her leadership because
she's just
always she's the hardest working person
and she's the most skilled person there
so you just it's you feel really
confident and comfortable
trusting her in that you know in that
leadership wow
you had some amazing
co-stars in this talented people
can we just talk about working with them
and just the brotherhood that comes
from making a film together yeah well i
mean
you know a little bit i mean we're still
friends after years after yeah
good goal and it's like when you work
with someone and you're in that
um you know in that crucible together
uh you know you form a bond on certain
projects not on every point but
but on projects that mean something um
you know you really come together and it
becomes like a little family
um because you are all so passionate
about making this thing
um everything that it can be and making
it excellent
and these guys i mean it was like a i
felt like i was back
at the cfc all over again a learning
experience for like
you know from all this with like
technical notes and like where to be and
where not to be and when you're
off screen making sure you're in the
right position to
um rehearsals and you know being quicker
with your decisions and rehearsals
because
you have to be able to know where you
what you want to get out of the scene
and do it in the rehearsal so that when
you're shooting you're not interrupting
everybody else's
uh choices yeah and then you know
working with leslie
you know he's a tony winner and just
such a phenomenal talent
one of the most generous people i've
ever met just preparing wisdom and
sharing knowledge and
um experience and you know we joked a
lot um
you know just had a great time as me and
leslie especially
and then with kingsley i mean i mean the
performance that he put up in the in the
intensity that he had on a daily basis
in in playing malcolm
um was just uh it was
amazing to watch i mean you see it on
the screen and then to be there
in that you know in that space and to
see him carry that with him when we go
back to the hotel
and him calling in the guys for
rehearsals after shooting
you know 13 14-hour days and when we got
a call time
for you know some of us got to get up at
4 00 a.m for different things
um hair and makeup or for me with
training and then
we'll be going into the late night with
rehearsals at this hotel and then come
in early in the morning for rehearsals
for those that day scenes and you know
um
yeah it was just an amazing experience
working with i feel like some of the
most talented people in the world
yeah what does it mean for you to make a
film like this
in 2020 with everything going on in the
world
black lives matter we're in a whole
different era
but to make something so groundbreaking
so impactful so meaningful what does
that mean to you